this is a coordinate plane two axis and
four quadrants how do we find the
distance between any two points say we
have two points a and B how do we find
this distance it's pretty simple let's
calculate the distance on the right hand
side of the whiteboard we need to find a
B the length of segment a B if you look
at the figure it lies entirely on the
x-axis in that case it's super easy to
find the distance between two points it
will be the absolute value of x2 minus
x1 x2 and x1 are simply the x
coordinates of the two points the x
coordinate of B is 4 and that of a is 1
so the distance between a and B will be
the absolute value of 4 minus 1 it will
be 3 units now look at line segment CD
which is parallel to x axis what will CD
be equal to guess what it is still the
absolute value of x2 minus x1 the
x-coordinates are 1 and minus 3 so the
distance will be absolute value of 1
minus minus 3 that will equal 4 units
don't get confused seeing the absolute
value sign you would probably have
guessed why we have it in the case of a
B even if we subtract 4 from 1 we still
get 3 units the distance is always
positive what's the length of line
segment EF when we say length of EF we
mean the distance between e and f what
will be H be equal to it lies entirely
on the y-axis the distance between any
two points on the y-axis is the absolute
value of the difference in the
y-coordinates the y-coordinates of E and
F are 2 and 0
EF will be the absolute value of 2-0 two
units and it will be the same for any
segment parallel to the y-axis take line
segment gh for example which is parallel
to the y-axis what is the distance
between G and H the y-coordinates of G
and H are 2 and minus 3 so gh will equal
absolute value of 2 minus minus 3 which
is 5 units finding the distance between
two points which lie on the axis or form
a line parallel to an axis is pretty
easy but what if we have to find the
distance between two points which do not
form a line parallel to an axis what if
we are asked to find the length of line
segment g d here this segment is not
parallel to any of the axes how do we
find its length let's erase this and
look at an example to understand this we
have been given the coordinates of G and
D and asked to find the distance between
them from the two points draw
perpendicular to the x axis and to the y
axis it's obvious that the angle formed
here will be a right angle we call it
point a now look at triangle G da and
you can probably guess how we can find
length g d yes triangle g d a is a right
triangle so if we find out G a and a D
then we can easily find G D using the
Pythagoras theorem we can easily find G
a and a D as they are parallel to the
axes based on the Pythagoras theorem G d
squared will equal G a squared plus a d
squared
now to find G a and AD we need to find
the coordinates of a that's easy x
coordinate of a is 3 and the y
coordinate is minus 2 using the concepts
we learned earlier we get G a
and AD as for and 2ga is the absolute
value of the difference in the
y-coordinates of G and a and AD is the
absolute value of the difference in the
x-coordinates of a and D solving this we
get GD squared as 20 taking the square
root on both sides GD will be 2 root 5
units this is interesting try and
understand what we did GT is the root of
4 squared plus 2 squared but what is 4
squared + 2 squared 4 is actually the
difference between the y-coordinates of
G and D and 2 is the difference between
the x-coordinates of G and D so can we
derive a formula to find the distance
between two points let's say G is X
comma Y and D is x1 comma y1 we can say
that the distance between two points
with these coordinates will be the
square root of x minus x1 squared plus y
minus y1 squared this is the distance
formula to find the distance between any
two points all we need is the
coordinates of those two points
you